[Music]
we landed in point lookout maryland down
here
and the day after we reached there
as a curious boy i rose pretty early we
just got in there the afternoon before
i lost pretty early and went out to see
how things looked around in there there
were 20 000 of us a large encampment
happening to look across in one
direction i don't know which
that was a flagpole
and a flag on it just rising
i stopped to look at it with curiosity
it stopped when it got halfway well i
knew what halfway
uh flagged
on a pole meant
i looked at it
i thought well
the rope that
animals have flagged must have a nut in
it and i'll see a man present going up
that's cold untimely
i waited a whole minute
and i casually turned my face in another
direction and there was another flagpole
with
flag halfness already so i
put my head in the temp there were five
six others of us i was boys there must
be some big yankee dead i wonder who it
can be of course we had no means of
knowing
and then
we waited
for about an hour
the sergeant blew a bugle we 150 of my
company
fell in and as soon as he finished
calling our names a number of us rushed
up the sergeant what does the half flag
mean
he stays there he says president lincoln
was shot last night
well
the uh the feeling that there are there
feeling that came over us 20 000 men in
just that one of course there were
several other prisons as you know
but as for me
and a boy just 19
i didn't know what to think i couldn't
feel in a hatred doing mr lincoln
especially
i didn't feel any special heated toward
any federal soldiers
and when i began to think
how kindly general grant efforts on the
nine acted toward
general lee
i
i felt kindly
[Music]